okay so hi everybody um my name is
Fraser
Hoff I'm here to present to you at this
edition of Bio conference live uh just
by way of introducing myself I'm a
professor of chemistry at the University
of Victoria this is a university on the
west coast of Canada uh my area of
research is in um recognition chemistry
uh chemical biology and most especially
the chemical biology of epigenetics
methylation Pathways uh stem cell
regulation and Cancers so I've been
asked to share a little bit about this
uh story with you today and I've also
been asked to share with you that um
this this talk talk is CME accredited
and so if you're after CME credits then
there will be a button on your screen at
some point that you can use to follow up
and obtain
those um the title of my talk is refers
to um the histone code and and
epigenetic methylation Pathways and stem
cancers and these I'm going to spend a
little bit of time warming us all up to
these these particular topics um so the
outline of my Talk starts with really an
interest production of epigenetics and
the histone code um we'll talk about
what histones are and how they work
going to talk about our our own groups
efforts to to do reading of the histone
code with a series of chemical sensors
um we're going to talk about how
methylation mechanisms um are epigenetic
mechanisms that control stem cells and
cancer cell behavior and finally we're
going to talk about um a therapeutic
approach that we're pursuing which is
which is chemical disruption of one
particular member of of these families
now um this is a bit of a wild card for
me it's hard to know exactly who your
audience is in these particular um in
these particular forums you know it's
quite an interesting online um session
I'm just going to ask a couple of poll
questions here that that I that I hope
you'll all take the time to answer and
the first one really is just for you to
categorize yourself
somehow um as one of these
categories so that I can really just
have an idea of exactly what audience
I'm talking
to okay
so thanks for those answers I'll just
kind of Pop the answers up here so you
get a little bit of an idea um it looks
like my audience today is mostly
researchers either on their way to a PhD
or with a PhD um there's a medical
doctor in the crowd there there are a
bunch of people who have actually just
joined in and didn't get to answer that
poll and so um we're going to continue
on the basis um now now whether you're a
researcher or a medical doctor I'm also
interested in knowing um what your
primary interest is when when you see
this title and you decide to attend this
talk so if you could answer this poll
question for me that would also be
really helpful for me to shakee the rest
of the the
content okay just waiting for a few more
answers to roll
in
okay so I I won't even push these
results back out to you but um
considering that you're all researchers
I'll just share that the primary
responses here were that you're
interested in cancer research and
epigenetics research um and and that
seems to follow nicely from uh your
identification of yourselves all as
researchers so okay so here we go um
enough of the Preamble um you know the
the the fact of genes existing in the in
the middle of our cells is something we
learned from a very early age in science
classes and and pictures like the one at
the top left of this screen here you
know our generic cartoon of a cell are
really routine and you always see the
dark patches in the middle and we're
told that this is the nucleus and this
is and this is where the the genetic
material is and it's called chromatin
and it's called chromatin because um it
refers to the dark color of that
substance in microscopic images from
very early days um now now Chrome tin in
fact um is is a packaging of DNA you
know the actual DNA the linear length of
DNA in any one nucleus in your body is
is six feet long so such that my hands
wouldn't even fit on the within the
camera view here um so that six feet of
DNA is packaged um into your nuclei uh
just like string is wound around a kite
spool and and that that the Spool in
this case are a family of proteins
called histones so histones have been
known for many decades to be DNA
packaging proteins and and you know that
our understanding of their functions was
really limited to just that simple
function that they were packaging um now
as many of you know as researchers the
the world of histone biology has
actually gotten very exciting in the
last 10 or 15 years and and I'm going to
talk to you a little bit about our our
interest in that today um just to lay a
little bit of groundwork here there's an
interesting thing about histones you
know histones or proteins um when DNA
replicates prior to cell
division you you just stands to reason
that you need twice as many histones to
make up for the fact that you have twice
as much DNA as the cell is preparing to
actually divide and become two daughter
cells what that means is that histones
are inherited so DNA is inherited and we
all understand that but histones are
inherited too and and this brings us to
a definition of epigenetics which is you
know Loosely defined um that EP genetics
refers to changes in gene regulation or
gene expression state that don't involve
changes in DNA sequence and in the
original definition this there's
reference also made to the fact that
these changes can be inherited so
everything I've told you so far implies
the fact that histones then are
inherited that they're not DNA
themselves but they have obviously
something to do with Gene
regulation so this gave rise to the
hypothesis um first first a phrase
coined in 2001 by yenu Vine and Alice
that there was a histone code and that
the histone code was the means by which
um um the readout of this code would be
controlling Gene regulation so what I
have cartooned here on this slide um is
is again another representation of
histones um we have here a sequence of
of a his Stone tail that's actually
projecting out from the core and what's
shown here is is a whole bunch of
cartoony ways of representing that these
hones actually are home to post-
transational modifications these are
chemical
modifications that actually um are
installed specifically onto different
histone residues um so this gives us the
metaphor of a histone code and if if
we're going to follow that metaphor
through to the end you know you'll see a
list on the slide that we have
methylation acetylation phosphorilation
Etc these are all different
modifications that can be made um those
modifications then in this metaphorical
sense are installed by enzymes that we
call writers so these are laying down
marks um they must be read by proteins
that actually bind to those
modifications and have the downstream
effect of turning a gene on or turning a
gene off or doing some other regulatory
event and if we're going to follow the
metaphor through to The Bitter End um
there are erasers and these are enzymes
that remove the side chain modifications
again and in my talk today I'm going to
talk to you briefly about a writer
enzyme just as an example I'm going to
talk to you about my own lab's interest
in in reading the histone code in
various
ways um the you know the fact that these
are Gene regulation Pathways really um
should tell all of us instantly that
they that they have a high relevance to
cancer I mean any kind of Gene
regulation pathway is co-opted by some
form of cancer and and these are well
understood when we talk about receptor
tyrosine kinases these are well
understood we talk about p-53 all of
these different systems whether they're
related to each other or not if they are
involved in gene regulation there's the
possibility they can be co-opted for
driving uh abnormal Gene regulation and
therefore abnormal growth of cells so so
just as an introduction there are many
many epigenetic targets um that are
currently being investigated as as as
possible sources for new therapy
I really do want to drive the point home
here that this is this is this is early
days in this family of approaches so
this is this is only a small selection
of targets I have listed on this slide
um that are related to um the histone
code or these histone modifications and
that are considered drug targets at
current time so uh the solid red arrow
on the in the middle of the slide refers
to um histone deacetylase that hdq one
and that's actually a a target for which
um actual drugs exist that are actually
used in the clinic that are FDA approved
and they're used in the management of
different
malignancies um but that's the only
solid red arrow on the screen because
because there are so few approved
epigenetic drugs and epigenetic Drug
targets that have actually been proven
the the dashed arrows um that point at1
L and
E2 um these are meant to indicate that
these are these are proposed drug
targets and and these These are the only
two agents among the ones listed on this
slide that have actually had agents
enter clinical trials these are just
phase one clinical trials just started
within the last 12 to 18 months um
pioneered mostly by a a a drug company
called episy whose name kind of says it
all you know they're they're a company
that believes strongly in in the promise
of these
approaches um besides that what we
really have here is a huge landscape of
promising targets and not so much um a
lot of validated targets so so that
these histone modifying enzymes on this
small list are at this point validated
drug targets that are showing responses
in human beings uh and and the whole
rest of this landscape is really not
yet so let's just really lay the last
little piece of groundwork here and
we're going to talk about methylation um
and we're going to talk about lysines
okay so I have pictured here a lysine
side chain and I just want to point out
that when when we talk about methylation
as a modification The Thing One Thing
very interesting to chemists in this
family um of modifications is that the
addition of one or two or three methyl
groups is really a subtle modification I
mean not only is the addition of a
single ch3 group um the most subtle
possible modification that one can
imagine in terms of making a new cove
valent Bond it's it's the smallest
modification in all of biology
um but but there's another important
feature here is that when a methyl group
is added one or two or three times the
charge on that lysing side chain doesn't
change uh the pka the ionization state
is hardly perturbed and so if this is
really unlike phosphorilation when when
when an alcohol group is phosphorated by
a kinas you have a bulk change to
negative negatively charged state that
has very big influence on binding
partners and on the structure of the
protein as phosphor ated and we really
these are much more subtle modifications
and one of the fundamental interests is
how such a small
modification can have such a big effect
when you think back to this original
picture that I showed you of
Chromatin so we have here kind of a
series of exploded views of Chromatin
and you know the
methylations just to show in cartoon
form here methylations might occur on a
single lysine residue that is on the
tail of a histone that's protruding from
this massive complex and even just a
single site being methylated can have
dramatic consequences for the actual
expression of the genetic information
I'll give some examples of that as we
move
forward so I feel like we're all on the
same page at this point and I'm going to
move on to talk about um the the idea
that we can use chemical sensors to
actually read the histone code and and
really what we're talking about here is
a new kind of analytical
approach um so I'll introduce you to a
family of molecules uh there's there's
one very simple example pictured in the
top right corner have another picture
coming up soon uh these molecules are
actually called CX
arines um and they're they're relatively
compact they're macrocyclic small
molecules and what we found uh early in
our research group is that is that these
particular molecules although we we
didn't never invented them um what we
found is that they're really beautifully
suited to um binding methylated residues
and and and there's a picture on the top
right of the screen here that kind of
implies something about the
three-dimensional structure of the
molecule they're called cxs because um
that's from the Latin for chalice or cup
shaped and so these molecules are
actually nicely a cup-shaped molecule
and and if you decorate them with the
right chemical functionality then you
make a cup that is actually a able to
bind other elements within it uh within
that that binding pocket so so there's a
picture shown on the screen now and the
green molecule is is a simple
kerine and the orange stick structure
here is actually a piece of histone and
it's a piece of histone tail that has a
trimethylene on it and what you can see
is that is that the methyl groups and
the lysine are buried inside of this
binding pocket um this this this model
is not just a flight of fancy this is
really built on on a lot of different
experimental evidence what we're
essentially doing here is is is in a
really fundamental way we're carrying
out a recognition event that constitutes
reading that methylation state and just
to put some numbers to go back and put
some numbers to this um these molecules
cixin have been well known to bind
various positively charged bits and
pieces of protein and bits and pieces of
other molecules but they have a really
special um per really perfect
complimentarity to the structure of
trimethine side chain and you can see
that in in the affinities here
essentially this this this simple
molecule has an affinity for
trimethylene that is as good as many of
the proteins that have evolved to do the
same recognition text uh the same
recognition task and and in fact it has
selectivities not quite as good as the
evolved proteins but still very
reasonable selectivities you know
70-fold selectivities over unmodified
proteins we can get that up over a
hundredfold with different modifications
easy selectivity over over positively
charged Arginine residues I mean there's
a there's a fortuitous complementarity
here in this family of
structs so how how might one
use this kind of structure to do an
analysis right so let's consider the
analysis tasks that are required to
begin with um you know the reason that
the histone modification are called a
histone code is because of the enormous
complexity and the enormous diversity of
the number of
modifications so I alluded before to the
fact that both methylation and
phosphorilation and acetylation can
happen and what one must consider to
understand the complexity of this is
that is that all of those things can
happen within a very small structural
Motif on a histone they can all happen
at the same time or they can happen
differentially um and the actual number
of permutations and combinations when
you consider all of the known
modifications on a single histone are
really staggering so one can very
quickly do a kind of backof the envelope
calculation and and and
factiously um find that um just
considering the number of different
known modifications that exist on a
single histone on on histone 3 the the
total number of different permutations
and combinations is far more than the
number of stars in the universe
okay and the reason I call that factious
is that there's no particular reason to
think that that number of different
modification States is relevant in
biology but but we do know that there
are definitely complexities here um that
make analysis challenging so as as these
analyses are done right now every one of
these analytes um whether it contains
one or two modifications or maybe three
modifications um they require one single
antibody and of course ant antibodies
are incredibly powerful tools the
problem is that they really don't work
very well on hstone tales and there's a
lot of
literature um there's a lot of
literature that tells us um explicitly
um quantitatively how bad the antibodies
are so
um the I had a question just come in
there and I'm going to answer feel that
question about cixin in just one more
moment when we get back there but but
thanks for that question question and
I'll point out to all of you that you
can definitely write in questions at any
point um and I'll definitely feel them
as they come in so so the way that
antibodies work is that every one
analyte that one might be interested in
requires a different antibody
now it's it's a bad idea as a chemist to
set out on the chaotic quest of
preparing the perfect super molecular
receptor for every possible
histone-based guest or every single
possible
modification uh the state of chemistry
is simply not good enough to do that so
really we talk about lock and key
recognition and and my starting point
here is that there is no such thing as
the perfect lock for every single one of
these keys so we need a different
approach and we take our inspiration
here from a completely different part of
nature um we take our inspiration here
from from a pattern recognition kind of
analysis that happens um in your nose
happens in in many other parts of nature
too um the nose is a great example every
human nose contains 391 different
olfactory receptors um when when you
smell a certain molecule so for example
um camp for um this is a natural product
it has a very characteristic smell it's
the smell of vix Vapor Rub if any of you
are familiar with that product um so
when C FL binds in your nose it doesn't
elicit a smell response in your your
brain because there is a camp for
receptor there are actually a family of
receptors that sense that particular
family of of smell compounds they
produce a pattern of signals that are
sent to your brain and your brain then
can can analyze that pattern and it can
determine that that pattern is the smell
of campur and in this way we have 391
different receptors but most humans can
easily identify and separate over 10,000
different smells and so it's this
pattern based
processing that allows us to tell many
things apart from few data points and
there are various chemists listed here
who have pioneered making chemical
sensor arrays that that can kind of
reproduce this this
feat so our first step then if we want
to do this with our macro Cycles is that
we really need to make um the macro
cycle binding event something that we
can we can get a readout from and the
simplest way to do this here is actually
to to use a fluorescent die as as a
proxy that tells us about binding so I
have a scheme here that shows What's
called an indicator displacement assay
and I have pictures of a particular die
and a particular host and a and a
trimethine in this example and just to
show you quickly um when you when you
add um the analy a trimethylene you
compete and you out compete the Dy some
Dy is is released into solution and that
die therefore gives you a numerical
response how intense is the responses
really simply how bright has your
solution
become excuse me and the way that this
looks in a 96 W plate is like this you
can see running vertically here we have
different amounts of brightness in a
particular row of wells and that just
corresponds to the actual visible
response we get from adding a piece of
histone to this particular series of
Wells so the we've made sensors and now
we need to make an array of sensors we
if we want a pattern of of of signals
then we really need to be able to
generate different data um from a given
analyte and so the way that we did this
was was to take a very simple approach
and we simply expanded our toolkit very
slightly we instead of using the one
parent Kix serine that I showed you
before we added two other Kix serines
and these things um have have each of
them the ability to bind the die but
each of them a different ability to bind
different histone modifications and I
really want to drive the point home here
that we did not program these things in
order to give a certain pattern we
didn't program them to be selective for
one modification another the the idea
behind this approach is really that you
don't need to program recognition you
can um add an analy to your array of
sensors in this case three different
sensors and you can get a response so
for example for arginine the letter r on
the graph at the top right we get a
pattern labeled a b and c from sensors a
a b and c you can see that the patterns
here are different for each particular
analy that we add and using some very
simple U mathematical processing we can
convert those patterns into a more
robust way of looking at the data um for
those of you interested in the details
this this is available in the paper if
you follow that reference this at the
bottom um we use methods called
principal component analysis or linear
discriminants analysis and these really
um they're complicated to explain but
they're very simple to execute and
they're routinely used in Diagnostics
science um and in environmental
monitoring and many other applied fields
of science but the point is that when we
do these measurements many times what
we're able to do is generate um data
distributions that tell us definitively
once we've trained our our set of data
uh what we're looking at and I'll show
you a couple of interesting examples
here before moving on to the next topic
um one can imagine that that we tackle
this problem problem of many and
different modifications on a particular
chunk of histone there's an example here
on on this slide where we have um an
acetylated piece an unmodified piece a
trimethylated piece and a piece that is
both trimethylated and phosphorated
these things are very easily
discriminated from each other by this
method even though the method isn't
designed to recognize any one of those
things um and we can get even more
different we can take trimethine or
should say more subtle we can take
trimethine um and we can basically look
at analytes that represent chunks of
trialing on different pieces of histone
so you can recognize here that the only
difference is in the sequence of the
backbone these are much more subtle
differences and some of these sequences
are even very similar and yet a simple
sensor array here made of only these two
molecules can tell these things apart
and moving forward quickly I just kind
of going to throw everything out there
for you right now to show that we can
take essentially any kind of histone
modification State and train our sensor
array on on the original output and then
probe with a blind analyte or with a
blind unknown sample and determine
exactly where these things are um on the
far left of the screen you can see um
one example where the these ovals these
confidence intervals are overlapping and
that happens only when we've made
analytes that essentially don't bind at
all to our sensors um and here and there
throughout the screen you can see things
that are really very closely related and
yet easily discriminated by this
method so that's one kind of biochemical
analysis if you think about what this
might be used for um there are
definitely um diagnostic applications
we're pursuing something we're pursuing
even more closely is the use of these
things as enzyme assays because we get a
very rich set of information out of
these things and the red dotted arrow
that I've just made up here on the
screen really represents the reaction of
a demethylase enzyme if you look at this
very small text we have H3 K9
me3 um those data arrive in one sector
and when we remove the methyl groups by
the process of an enzyme um which is a
demethylase enzyme selective for that
substrate then then we can we can very
robustly read that enzyme reaction out
in a really information Rich way and
that's something we're very interested
in pursuing as research tools we have
both diagnostic applications and
research tools that we're developing
based on this this fundamental
technology and I I recognize that many
of you in the audience are probably
biochemists or or cell biologists and so
I I would be remiss if I didn't mention
that that these reagents are actually
also really well suited for doing um
pull downs and interfering with pull
Downs in a variety of ways so pull Downs
are really a bread and butter tool um
for for many biological research
Searchers in these areas and so this is
why we headed in this direction uh with
the help with of collaborators at the
University of
Colorado you know we're able to show
that our that our molecules are
effective enough at doing their job
whatever it is we've programmed them to
do um in this example to bind a
methylated histone tail that they can
robustly interfere with pull Downs um
and in other arrangements um where we
actually have the kerin themselves on
solid support they can do the pull Downs
um they really work very well with this
whole mode of experimentation and that
plays nicely um for fundamental studies
of interactions among biomolecules and
also using these things as as reagents
leading into proteomic studies um so
there's something I I I want to make
very clear here the these macrocycles
although they bind to methylated
histones that are related to disease
States we really don't pursue the
development of these things as drugs and
that's simply because they're
fundamentally not druglike and we think
it would be
a bad idea to spend a lot of effort
trying to get them to be drugs um with
that said they can have impacts in cells
and we've shown that they can get into
cells uh we just feel they just don't
have the right physical chemical
properties or pharmacological properties
in order to really be explored um
as as reagents sorry as Therapeutics in
any realistic way but as reagents they
promise to be powerful tools for a
variety of things so I'm just going to
return to a question um that I had
earlier about the kerine and I'll return
to it here because I have a nice picture
in the top right corner the question was
what are the features of the Kix
macrocycle and methylated lysing that
are responsible for the good affinity
and the reason I waited until I had this
picture come back up to answer that
question is because it's really nicely
shown in the top right corner here and
and in the left side um the the
important features in order probably in
order are are um electrostatic
attraction between the sulfinate which
is negatively charged and the side chain
which is positively charged that
explains our basic level of affinity for
for any kind of
Lysine um when the methylation happens
on the lysine side chain that sideen
becomes slightly bigger it fits the
pocket better it becomes much more
hydrophobic and if you look inside of
that green pocket from this top down
view you can see that um you have there
a big patch of hydrophobic surface area
and so that very much helps to drive the
binding um and we've done various
control experiments to to know that
that's that's true that hydrophobicity
is very important and finally um the the
most canonical of these interactions
that most people would have seen first
is actually the Caton Pi interaction I
actually have a diagram of the cation Pi
interaction a little later in the talk
but basically the idea is that the the
pi electrons on these Benzene Rings uh
that that Define the walls of The
Binding pocket have a partial negative
charge that's very nicely complementing
the partial positive charge on the
methyl groups um that bind inside of
it okay so I think that's question is
answered and uh I do encourage the rest
of you to take cracks at me with
questions at any point going forward so
okay let's talk about cancer a little
bit more directly um there are many
examples of histone methylation being
involved in cancer Pathways and I I
can't possibly cover them all here so
I'm going to give you one quick example
of two related families um and in these
families what we're talking about are
methylation events that happen to drive
the silencing of tumor suppressor genes
and you can imagine if you silence a
tumor suppressor then you're going to
promote growth and you're going to
promote
cancer so in this particular example
which is just one of hundreds of such
examples we're looking at a gene here
the gene is
cdkn2a that is a gene that encodes a
tumor suppressor um I'm going to show
you first um the rer protein E2 um
that's a methyl transferase enzyme it
methylates a histone site um that is in
the promoter region for this Gene and
you can see in the bottom of again my
cartoon for methylation being installed
and so ez2 is strongly correlated with
the silencing of this Gene and therefore
um with with a variety of aggressive and
metastatic Cancers and so here I refer
to some data from the company
epizyme um they have methyl transferase
Inhibitors of a few different kinds uh
really interesting different chemotypes
involved the one shown here is an ez2
inhibitor they reported on
recently in
pnas and and this really is just shown
because it's a nice demonstration of the
concept okay um in the in the cancerous
cell in this particular study um the
tumor suppressor cdkn2a is silenced
because of the action of
E2 the addition of the E2 inhibitor um
creates um uh let's say it blocks
methylation and they can show that
definitively and the blocking of the
methylation leads to Restoration of
expression of the tumor suppressor and
so then if you look at the graph on the
right what we have here are some tumor
volume curves uh in in a in a mouse
model for this particular malignancy and
you can see here A do dependent response
um that's sustained over time where
treatment with the agent that inhibits
E2 is actually very significantly
knocking the cancer completely out and
so the the Paradigm here is that if you
rescue the tumor suppressor then you're
treating the cancer um this particular
agent is not the one that's in clinical
trials right now but the same company
has a related um agent that has the same
mode of action that is in clinical
trials right now uh just in Phase One
show showing some some interesting
results that they've been disclosing in
small
pieces okay so um that's an example of
how epigenetic drugs might work I'm
going to talk next about another part of
this exact same um family of results
which is a methy liing reader protein
called cbx7 so I'll go back to this
cartoon and what I didn't mention before
is that if a methyl group is installed
it really doesn't do anything until
something else binds to it and and
that's that's the family of proteins we
call reader proteins and this is a
family my my group is very interested in
so the reader protein in this particular
pathway uh that that mates with this
writer and this tumor suppressor uh is
called cbx7 so it it reads methyl
groups and this is actually just now a
scattering of different um pictures of
complexes from different reader proteins
reading methyl groups and so what we
have here are um the Great
structures are different reader proteins
and the green structure is a highlighted
trimethine and there's something
interesting that you'll see here these
are very diverse and unrelated reader
proteins but they all look a lot like
the kerine they all have aromatic
residues arranged in a cup shape that
surround the methylated side chain and
that that's that binding Motif is called
sometimes the aromatic cage um and it
takes advantage of the same interactions
as did the kerine it has cation Pi
interactions depicted at the bottom
center of this slide it has Vander
Fall's interactions that have to do with
filling the space properly and it very
much relies on the hydrophobic effect in
order to achieve the selectivity for the
methylated state um and I'll point out
here although it's not on the slide
there are also electrostatic
interactions that are important in that
there are very often carboxilate side
chains very close to the um very close
to the ACT ual methylated side chain so
if I can just highlight these things
here there's an example and there's
another example those are negatively
charged side chains in the reader
protein that are very close in
complimenting and giving that minus
attract to positive kind of interaction
also okay I have another question coming
in
here oh sorry um I just didn't quite
state that clearly the The Motif here is
called the aromatic cage and and that's
simply a reference to the fact that um
these aromatic residues are typically
arranged so that they're each in a cage
around the methylated side chain in
different
ways okay so what does cbx7 do what is
its biology well it turns out that cbx7
is very tightly involved in the
regulation of stem cells both embryonic
stem cells and adult stem cells so these
are cells that can become lots of
different things
um we've we've done none of this work
you know the the work of biology comes
before the chemists like me get involved
um but I can just point to the work of
Emily
Bernstein um Dean uh deochi these are
like Pioneers in understanding cbx
biology and especially how it relates to
Stem Cell regulation so just to give you
a very brief snapshot of that um in stem
cells cbx7 is is silencing multiple cell
cycle checkpoint proteins
uh in doing so it has the specific
outcome of maintaining PL potency in
stem cells and giving a general
proliferative signal in stem cells and
if you find loss of cbx7 in a particular
stem cell population then what you have
is actually the the the state of the
stem cells becomes less stemlike they
differentiate and they become exhausted
or they just become other kinds of cells
they're not stem cells anymore so stem
cell is really a master regulator that
that makes a stem cell a stem cell that
gives cells stem-like
properties and so it's very easy then to
imagine how it is that these that these
features of cbx7 in in normal stem cells
can be co-opted in cancer so I've
already said that it silences multiple
cell cycle checkpoint proteins of course
cell cycle checkpoint proteins are very
often also called tumor suppressors um
upregulation of cbx7 is has been
identified in several cancer it predicts
poor outcome in several cancers although
I'll be clear here not all cancers on
the profiles are different in different
tissues if you knock down cbx7
expression you strongly reduce
proliferation in in cultured cancer
cells of a few different types um and
stem cells of some types and I'll just
point out that um very importantly for a
medicinal chemist um these proliferative
effects of
cbx7 um uh depend on cbx7 having a
competent me methy liing binding domain
and if you look at the actual curves
that are shown here um the ones of
Interest are um cbx7 wild type which is
the red curve and
cbx7 W 35a these particular authors uh
in this paper they used a construct
where a single tryptophan that binds a
methine was mutated away and they showed
that that completely shut down methy
binding and in fact then what you get is
this so so you don't have any of the
proliferative effect that you normally
see
um
for um normal cbx7 driven proliferation
so this is all related to cancer cell
growth it's also related very tightly to
stem cells and and to sum up a lot of
controversial
literature um stem-like cancers are a
subset of cancers that are aggressive
and very hard to treat and we think that
cbx7 antagonists will will halt
proliferation in cancer stem cells and
in other hardt treat cancers where cbx7
is is a driver of
aggression okay so how do we do this so
we're going to back up and think back to
the molecules because this this isn't a
validated Target and in fact no methyl
reader protein is a validated drug
Target um at this point so we don't have
kit assays that we can use we need to
develop our own assays and and our
favorite assay in this family is called
fluoresence
polarization fluorescence polarization
here simply takes advantage of the fact
that we have a
die attached to um a piece of histone
and the rate of tumbling of that Dy
gives us uh is a readout that we can
actually very easily measure in any
simple Plate Reader and so um this
readout is called fluorescence
polarization uh you're certainly welcome
to look that up if you want more details
but in a in a nutshell um in the
presence of the complex we have we have
high signal and when we disrupt that
complex with a proper inhibitor then we
have signal go down okay and just to
show the example of many
replicates um here is an example of many
replicates of data where we have high
signal for fluorescence polarization and
here's our positive control set where we
have um many um very easily reproduced
positive results which is a decrease in
fluoresence polarization
okay so our approach to do this um um
was actually not high throughput
screening initially uh the these targets
are very hard to screen against they
have a lot of practical difficulties
that make their High throughput screens
um difficult to succeed with and so what
we started with is actually the histone
sequence um that we know cbx7 binds it
binds to a certain methylated histone
tail and so we started with that and now
we're just going to run through the step
steps that a chemist takes when they're
trying to start from a
peptide really start from a protein and
make something that is actually a useful
tool for binding um and so the first
step is to truncate that sequence to a
minimal length and so we started with a
14 amino acid long peptide we found we
could get as low as five amino acids
long without losing too much
Affinity the Second Step also not shown
in detail here is that we really messed
around with the sequence of the peptide
at that point quite significantly so
that we could get a better starting
sequence than the native histone tail so
we still just have peptides here um our
third step was actually to show that the
fluoresence polarization assay is is
reporting all of the structure activity
relationship that we want it to and so
here I have some red arrows showing
these are simply ic50 values lower
numbers means more potent um if we
remove the methyl
groups then the Affinity goes to
immeasurable ably low so we know that
our our peptide still relies on
methylation in order to bind um here's
here's another example if we actually
make a modification
here that particular methyl group is
this methyl group it's buried in a cozy
little pocket in the structure and so we
anticipated that if we made it any
bigger that it would destroy binding or
completely remove binding and sure
enough we identify that again we have
the predicted structure activity
relationship if we make it a little
bigger we completely remove
binding uh a much more thorough
accounting of all of this by the way is
reported in our own paper in jmed cam um
published earlier this year lots of
steps that we can skip over uh for the
purposes of this talk so we have a
crystal structure uh it shows a really
nicely closed binding site and a closed
binding site is good for for expecting
uh small molecule Affinity of of drug
like compounds and to cut this long
story very short um we basically were
able to start with this five amino acid
long peptide that's pictured on the
left and uh by making only 63 different
compounds almost all of these compounds
were were were prepared by very simple
solid phase synthetic steps we're able
to arrive at something uh an example of
which is shown on the right which is a
modified structure here a Pepto mimetic
uh the arrows here refer to um things
that are that are not peptid like we
have a cyclopentane we have a particular
dial tail we have a big aromatic group
on the end these things each were found
to be very beneficial for
binding and and so then by the time
we've done this this iterative iterative
optimization we've gone from compounds
that are about 30 micromolar in the
original Parent case down to compounds
that are actually 200 nanomolar Affinity
so so we're now at affinities that are
that are much stronger than the wild
type interaction we can show in many
ways that they're able to out compete
the while type interaction we're able to
do some nice studies that show that
we're really quite selectively on target
with these particular tool
compounds okay so um I I'll just say
here that we do have um results from
these compounds that suggest their
promise um we have a lot of unpublished
results um on their behavior in various
different cancer cells especially
considering stem like cancers as Prime
targets here um the we have liability
here and that these compounds are peptid
like and so they don't have very good
cell
permeability but we do have here the
first example of any inhibitor of any
particular methyl reader in this family
and and just to kind of Zoom back out
and give you the context um there's a
very nice series of figures here that
are provided by the structural genomas
Consortium uh in in Toronto and in
Oxford so so they have this beautiful
online resource called Chromo Hub and it
really tells you everything you want to
know about chromatin related proteins
but it especially tells the chemist what
they want to know about what chemistry
has been done on different proteins and
so what we have here is is is a series
of families what they have in common is
that they're all methyl readers so these
are domains that bind to methylene like
the cbx7 that I showed you um when when
we started this project there were there
were no Inhibitors of any methyl readers
in any family while we worked on the
project um there have been a nice
example or two um of Inhibitors in other
families so MBT domains have have one
inhibitor for one prominent member of
that family that's available another
family of domain is called phds um they
they have one family published out of
the University of Wisconsin uh the
result on mbts was a result of work at
the University of North Carolina and the
structural genomic Consortium themselves
and and each of these came from
essentially from screening results um
but as I've mentioned screening is quite
challenging in these families and so our
our peptid driven approach here has
given us compounds that are represented
by the the three arrows up here in the
in the Chromo domain family and so um
these three arrows represent three
different molecules that we've made that
are Inhibitors of of different cbx
proteins um the point of this slide is
really to show how much of this
landscape is
untouched more so than to highlight what
has been done before each of these
reader proteins has been correlated to
really dramat or many of them have been
tied to very dramatic impacts in stem
cell regulation and in cancer cell
regulation um and there's a lot of room
for Medicinal Chemistry Explorations in
this area and if there's anyone take-
home message I would say that it's this
there is a lot of Promise in this field
and there's a lot of of room for work to
be done and what's needed is is for
chemists uh and other researchers to
focus on making tool compounds in order
to learn which of these things is worth
pursuing and which of them um is is less
worth pursuing but really to take
advantage of of the therapeutic
potential so it remains for me only here
to answer some questions before I do
that I'll just point out that I'm very
grateful to to various funders uh many
of which are charitable organizations so
those include things like motorcycle
rally called Ride to Live prostate
cancer Canada the movember uh people uh
who are also prostate cancer uh
fundraisers Prostate Cancer Foundation
of BC a lot of this work in the second
half of the talk was funded by those
groups and on the tools development side
of things the funding is primarily from
nerk and from genome
BC um the students who do this work just
to finish off last of all are fantastic
we have incredibly high quality highly
motivated students here at our
University I'm grateful for them every
day and I just want to leave you with
their happy smiling faces here uh to as
a sign off um before I take any
questions um that that's all I have to
say please if you have any questions
feel free to fire them away at me
now okay nothing
imminent couple of questions answered
juring so um that's it I'm I'm going to
sign off of this session oh wait a
question just came
in the question says for reader assays
dot dot dot is there more question to
follow all right actually things are
hopping now
let's let's see what I can do okay um
one question for reader assays um from
activx biosciences how about Mass Spec
approaches for omix wide readouts um so
that that's an awesome suggestion um the
mass speec people the proteomics
community I think have done an amazing
job in the last three years at really
refining how to do methylation based
analyses um we if I can back up and talk
about the kerine type reagents that
we're developing one of our primary uh
goals is to be able to make pull down
reagents out of kerin that will
facilitate proteomics wide um analyses
so you know consider them as a
pre-enrichment step on a digested sample
before going into Mass Spec that you can
have many more methylated interesting
Targets in the actual soup that you're
trying to analyze when you're doing that
that lcmsms based approach um there's a
multiple reaction monitoring and mrm
approach that allows you to see where
residues have been
methylated um none of those things have
really hit um the big time in terms of
being used as Diagnostics but in terms
of research developments there are
definitely things going on in that
area um have a question from uh quantell
Pharmaceuticals is prostate cancer a
potential indication for
cbx7 we we think the answer to that is
yes uh and other cbx7 proteins might be
relevant here also um and we've been
we've been working quite quite um
closely with uh researchers who are
Prostate Cancer Specialists and and the
the short version of that story is that
um in castrate resistant prostate cancer
and in uh the transition from hormone
sensitive to hormone independent
prostate cancer we see a role for
cbx7 now whether you call that
transition to hormone Independence or
the transition to castrate resistant
prostate cancer um whether you call
those clinical markers Bonafide um stem
cell like transitions I think is a very
open question and I wouldn't speculate
whether their um the stem cell story is
very tightly related there but the
general idea that cbx7 is correlated
with aggression seems to be um uh solid
enough to to follow up on and that's one
of our approaches
here any other
questions okay so thank you very much
all for attending um hanging out till
till the end I'm going to sign off now
and um thank the org organizers also for
this pretty cool
opportunity I uh hope you all got
something out of it and of course you
can find me online if you want to send
any more questions my way thanks so much
and
bye